[Music]
welcome back to this episode thank you
for welcoming me back well and then who
just not Kermit Oh everybody but Kermit
speaking of Kermit Kermit's diet
consists of farmers dog and he loves it
he he loves it so much that when we're
not feeding him farmers dog he cries for
it so thank you some farmers dog it is
an incredible service that feeds your
dog human grade recipes developed by
board certified veterinary nutritionists
and you can go to the farmers comm slash
annejulien
to get started get 50% off your first
two week trial of fresh healthy food at
the farmers dog.com slash annejulien
check out or click link down below so
you're gonna be annoying they're gonna
be nice
well they're always annoying but they're
gonna be especially annoying because
what do we have today
something that seemeth want
we have mug pizzas that jenna has made
us specifically for this podcast yeah
cuz I was hungry well and it's a great
to go snack the last time that I made a
mug Pizza you're you're just gonna have
to deal with it there's food on the
table they're very excited the last time
that I made a mug Pizza was when you got
your wisdom teeth out oh my gosh yes you
were taking such good care of me well
you wanted a chocolate mousse which I
made from avocado I think it was super
good and I made you mug pizza which you
loved I love it you're a hungry boy I'm
a hungry boy and you just wanted
something savory yeah there's a lot of
like really sweet things like smoothies
and yeah I mean usually people eat like
jello and Sun when ice cream when they
get their wisdom teeth out I wanted to
soup some meals yeah he wanted pizza and
hot and sour soup those are the two
things you made me when I have my wisdom
teeth on and I cut all the tofu up into
tiny little pieces for you
take such good care of me so I made this
mug pizza for you mm-hmm and the recipes
on Pinterest for those of you that are
interested Pinterest coms last gen in
Julian no no oh you don't have a podcast
Pinterest and it's basically flour
baking powder baking soda salt you whisk
the dry ingredients together then you
put a tablespoon of milk a tablespoon of
olive oil a tablespoon of pizza sauce
which we made which we had in the fridge
frozen made pizzas easily made eats of
the other day and then little cheese
some Italian herbs and we put some vegan
pepperoni topping and I made sure to
microwave yours first so that you were
forced to let it cool for a second hey
you got to stop screaming it's not so
good dude oh my god all right good
I thought we could have a nice special
treat yeah so if you're listening or
watching the podcast and you're able to
grab a snack and join us or don't you
yeah whatever weird snack you got going
on because I mean this is sort of a
pantry special right here there's a
pantry special which is I'm grateful to
even have food so I'm excited any Cheers
you know it's weird it's rare that you
get to choose your dinner also you don't
need tomato sauce to make this you could
just make a light pie version of it
honestly you just microwave whatever you
think flour and cheese mmm it's really
good
oh that's so good there's a lot of mug
like cakes and like stuff you can
microwave on Pinterest yeah mug meals
mug meals here's a business idea mug
meals on wheels you deliver mug meals
mm-hmm no no about mug meals for mug
meals on wheels you deliver mug meals to
those delivery men who work for mug
meals on wheels that's really thoughtful
of you Julian but no I got more years
crank puzzle it's a puzzle gift you can
get someone but if there's always one
piece missing out in the box that is
torture that's sick
bring puzzle that's so sick
it also has a camera inside the box I
didn't realize we were on Shark Tank
right now
we're always on Shark Tank we kind of
are I kind of always am with you you're
my shark we've been watching old
episodes of Shark Tank the old ones are
really good it's just it's such a
different show now than it was when it
started like is there like nice to these
people and not trying to take like 70%
of their small business yeah I mean they
really played into the shark kind of
persona and they were all I felt like
they all got bonuses for being mean
because they all really just were mean
when they didn't have to be yeah like I
don't like you and her like don't don't
don't it hey I think you're a [ __ ] guy
get out of here and then the person
leaves yeah like oh the hell is this oh
my god Barbara was savage a couple times
she was like you know what I really
respect your work ethic I think you're
great but this product is awful yeah
this idea sucks Jesus Christ dude chill
we also along with a lot of people just
finished tiger King oh my goodness
what a wild [ __ ] ride it was a wild
ride it was a wild ride from start to
finish it doesn't seem like it's over no
well because at the end spoiler alert if
you hadn't finished it we're gonna be
talking about it I guess
they talked about how Doc antle's kind
of spa was rated in December which was
three months ago for almost four months
ago so you have to imagine that like by
the time that they had wrapped
production of all this in documentary
and had everything kind of edited that's
when that happened so you have I mean
you have to believe that they're already
filming like part two or whatever but
holy [ __ ] dude like talk about
interesting personalities meets like
underground world that nobody knew about
meets crazy criminal [ __ ] it's like all
it's like the most juicy entertainment
like in one series that I've ever
watched and it's weird because I know
that like a lot of the people in the
documentary Joe exotic da cantle Jeff I
mean like so many of the people that
they document Carol they're they do bad
things and they have qualities about
them that on paper you're like you're
you're not a good person like things
that you're doing don't pick them up he
needs to stay it's okay he'll get over
it a lot of them have qualities were you
like okay you're not that great I
shouldn't be rooting for you but then
they have some of them have redeeming
qualities where you're like man I like
you though that's what I thought about
Joe exotic especially one of the most
interesting parts about the whole series
is that everyone is so like violently
human yes everyone has like these good
parts about them in these horrible parts
and that that's what it is to be a human
being yeah yeah and that's what makes
this like such a weird unrelatable topic
of a documentary so relatable and I
think so interesting to so many people
because like you said it's like oh this
isn't a movie
these aren't characters that are written
perfectly to be whatever characters they
are they're [ __ ] people
yeah oh [ __ ] man there are a lot of
moments that I felt I
I don't know this problematic or
whatever but I felt bad for Joe exotic
and like he made me want to like root
for him
you know and man like some so much sad
[ __ ] happened to him even though he was
you know a criminal and did bad things
and like talked about killing this woman
and allegedly you know put a hit on her
whatever and killed animals but like I
mean it's just weird it's weird how it
makes you feel like that like so
conflicted but the whole the whole time
you're just like like you you just you
were an episode ahead of me or two
episodes ahead of me for a day or two
and you were like you're not ready for
what's about to happen and that's
exactly what it is it's like every step
of the way you're like blindsided by
what the [ __ ] is happening next you just
can't even and the fact that they have
so much footage like Wow
just I mean just the idea alone like da
cantle having all of these wives mm-hmm
that is a show on TLC done Sister Wives
like just their personal lives alone is
a great show yeah but you put it all
together like what the hell is going on
mm-hmm
Wow so what do you thinks gonna happen
next
it's a jet flow anything's happened to
Jeff Lowe oh I think that they're all
gonna go down I mean at the end of the
series you know obviously they point out
during all of this the animals aren't
winning yeah you know like no good has
really come out of this for the animals
yeah everyone's just like screwing each
other over and trying to some of that
legal stuff with Carole Baskins was like
the the it was horrible the way that she
sued his mother and was suing everybody
like that is a nightmare that is
absolutely horrible yeah I mean yeah
someone threatening to kill you and and
all like it's all terrible and I just
it's like fighting fire with fire
like back and forth until both of their
lives are just like destroyed I know no
one wins nobody was especially not the
animals it's like what they said like if
you bring him up here he's not gonna
want to save me a shirt either he's
gonna go for your food like he's a
problem you have to suck one person I
never really felt for was Jeff Lowe I'd
never liked him I don't think anyone
like I don't know how you could like
that guy but yeah I mean the like
another interesting part of the series
is right like there are these mortal
enemies right Carole Baskin and Joe
exotic they like they're like sent to
earth to destroy each other like they're
just so like the rivalry knows no bounds
and her whole argument is you know he is
exploiting and abusing animals and they
mentioned it a little at the beginning
but it's like well what are you doing
over here what is Big Cat Rescue like
what are you actually doing what is your
facility look like what is your mission
how much do you pay your employees Oh
none how much do you make Oh
millions like it's very weird it's pot
calling the kettle black a whole lot
that I feel like what's glazed over yeah
and I mean not to like hey Carm you have
to stop but not to glaze over the fact
that he literally allegedly was
convicted yeah like he put it he put a
hit out on her yep just horrible no but
what is really sad about all the the
legal processes to me is that the person
that has more money has the ability to
keep this going in to run the show to
just destroy this other person this is
our life by the way this is I mean no
barrel for that mug pizza right now
okay I'm gonna hug you because he's
screaming yes we love staying home with
our family every day yes it is
interesting though because but isn't
that the money runs the show stop that's
fair all of you I mean people have
talked about this for so long in our
country in particular about how unfair
the legal system is and how people with
more money can exploit it and just bury
other people and that's terrifying and
sad yeah and I think the one of the best
lines from the show was the producer of
the reality show yeah I liked him that
was saying I mean they're both doing the
same thing they're both exploiting these
cats for money and they're they're just
they think that the other ones the evil
one no but Carroll Baskins just had more
money than him yeah and then dude like
beneath that whole rivalry the [ __ ]
mystery about her ex-husband I mean
there's so much about that story that
just creeps you out especially like I
don't think the creepiest thing about
that whole saga is how she talks about
it
because when you like when you watch
footage of I don't know like widows
right talking about their late husband's
or whatever it's like most of the time
in like whatever documentary or whatever
it is as long as it's real you feel that
like emotion you're like oh my god this
person is hurting and they've been
hurting for so long and they got their
loved one taken and for at least for me
I never felt like she was giving off any
of that energy when she was talking
about it in fact she was like laughing
during a lot of that those questions
about how ridiculous the accusations
were and like how hilarious the thought
of her like feeding him to the Tigers
would be and like how it is just like
nothing about her talking about that
made me feel like she was innocent yeah
and I mean that's people grieve in
different ways and it was a long time
and you know people sometimes don't
emote the same way that other people do
yeah but I agree with you that some of
the stuff she was saying didn't
necessarily feel genuine mm-hmm no it
felt weird but you can't let's you know
no that's our job as a Netflix Watchers
we have to form opinions what that's
what I'm saying you can't convict
someone of murder just because they
they're talking about it a little weird
no for sure it just gave me the creeps
it gave me the creeps as well are you
done no I'm just trying not to eat it
cuz he's screaming in city take a bite
in front of him oh he does wrong he were
about a peanut farmers dog after the
podcast speaking of farmers dog it's a
really great service if you want to get
your dog some food that they're really
gonna enjoy and benefit from because
it's good for them when they use whole
real ingredients but just same way oh
that was like five minutes ago I'm I'm
cruising now if you guys haven't heard a
farmer's dog yet or you haven't tried it
it is basically high quality dog food
for your dog that is made really easy
and they send it to your house and
prepackaged amounts so you can measure
exactly how much your dog should eat you
go on their website
you enter a bunch of different answers
about your dog how much they weigh what
breed they are what their eating habits
are things like that and they put
together a whole meal plan that you
don't even have to worry about you don't
have to hey you need to calm down
she wants her farmers done you don't
need to do the research there they're
handling all that okay they're certified
and they're putting the good ingredients
that your dog needs and actually really
really wants in these packages of food
and if you have a picky eater like we
did with marbles farmer's dog solved
that problem and now they love dinner
they get so excited so if you go to the
farmer's dog calm slash Jenna Julianne
right you you get started with your own
subscription for your own pet or pets
and you get 50% off your first two week
trial of healthy food for your dogs and
I I really feel like if you're on the
fence about it your dog trying it is
gonna tell you everything you need to
know there's a good product that your
dog will love and they'll be on a
healthier time and it's at a very high
convenience to you it's delivered to
your door you don't have to go shopping
for it is nice it is convenient so check
it out click the link below and get
started thanks the farmers are well last
week I was reading some of the comments
and you guys were a few of you were let
down that I didn't segue because we had
no sponsors last week because we weren't
supposed to podcast last week yeah we're
supposed to be a wedding supposed to be
a wedding obviously we're not and um I
just want to a few of you guys who
missed my shot with my segue but you
know shout out to you guys and for
appreciating the segways I'll squeeze
another extra one in sometime soon that
you won't be ready for I don't think we
need that well squeeze an extra one
aren't there winning that this is really
good mom dude
hey some are mug eating sounds I finish
mine you did oh okay I have one more
bite we gonna make mud cakes after this
mm-hmm without watching these okay
that's disgusting yeah how long the mic
did you get it off yep
what was the what was the point of that
jetski shot at the end memes is that
just for memes I think so cuz it seems
so random and they probably paid a lot
for that song probably one of my
favorite parts of the entire series was
Joe and Travis and what was the other
one's name [ __ ] I loved him what is his
name he had two first names the three of
them having a three-way marriage that
was great I loved the footage of their
wedding of them wearing the matching
pink shirts yeah I just I really I
thought that was delightful
I would have liked John Finley yes I
would have liked to attended that
wedding yeah wow that was that was a
dope wedding I also really I mean
throughout the series I feel like you
start to I mean like I said this before
but like the people they are
interviewing like John Finley right and
one of the keepers the one with there
were two characters with no legs right
or was that there was two I'm pretty
sure or was that the same guy I'm pretty
sure there were two maybe I'm mistaken
anyway one of them I really started to
like him the one who left his wife at
the end mm-hmm like him John Finley like
the girl who lost her arm like these
people you just like start to really I
don't know you just like you like them
and you empathize with them and
regardless of the fact that you know
they're in this crazy world that you had
no idea about you like I know they just
become like your allies in this in the
story as it gets crazier and crazier and
people start to really show their ugly
sides
you know yeah I mean yeah I just I think
it you see one part of Joe where it's
like he goes to the bus station and
picks up someone and gives them a chance
to work and have a place to live and
like what a lovely thing to do and
hiring people out of prison and giving
them jobs and stable income and some
food and a trailer like cooking
Thanksgiving dinners for the community
and then you know he does things like
cooking Thanksgiving dinner for the
community for the community and then you
find out that he took that money to fund
a hitman to fund it to fund a hit what
how outrageously I mean it's it's human
imagine that you're right you're right
it's like here's this amazing thing you
did and then here's this horrible
horrible yeah and then like you know
towards the end they do a nice callback
to like the original footage of when he
first started the zoo and how he's
talking on camera about he really does
feel for the animals and he wants to
make a difference and all that gets lost
throughout his his career as this guy
and this eccentric owner of cats it's
and I don't know it's just this like
crazy transformation that you watch and
what's I think it's just the documentary
is so dynamic and it's so like immersive
just because there is an insane amount
of footage from all the different time
periods
yeah you know throughout the story it's
you know I don't feel like I'm not used
to watching a documentary where I'm
literally like there was maybe one or
two reenactments the rest was like
[ __ ] footage yeah it's like how did
they get this how do they have all of
this all the time it was it's just a
little unbelievable humbling but like
what's the driving force is it like does
it seem like the people like da cantle
are a little like you have to step he's
a problem dog food you can't have mug
pizza don't bite me again it's a problem
dog you you have people like Doc Hansel
who I think
his motivation is sort of he's like
drunk on this power of having these
exotic animals whereas it seemed like
someone like Joe was a little bit
financially and like ego motivated it's
sort of the same thing yeah yeah but
they both make money off of it and they
like the attention that it brings them
and it becomes part of their identity
yes exactly
yeah it's wild it's it's fun crazy
because as much of a part of Joe exotics
identity is it is doc antle's identity
is it is Carol bass Jeff love they like
wrap themselves up into it so much
that's who they are yeah and it makes
them do crazy things when they think
that it's being threatened because they
don't I mean the the closest thing I can
compare it to I guess from my brain is
like when you're an athlete your entire
life and then you have an injury that
makes it so you can no longer play your
sport you have like this like well Who
am I this is my whole life yeah you know
for these people they're so wrapped up
in these worlds that you know anything
that will come in and threaten that is
like well then who the [ __ ] am I even
after like if this is gone yeah yeah
yeah
I don't know watching when they talked
about da canto and they would kind of
show and interview some of the girls who
used to work for him and all the crazy
sex stuff that would happen and like
teenagers like horrible [ __ ] a lot of
that felt like I was watching something
that was not in America like it did not
feel like it was America in this country
that like when they had these huge like
estates and you go behind the [ __ ]
closed doors are these crazy properties
and there's just doing whatever the [ __ ]
they want
they have illegal animals they're doing
illegal things they're basically sex
trafficking I mean it's like
unbelievable and you're just like this
is in [ __ ] Oklahoma or wherever
where's doc Hansel that maybe I don't
know whatever it's just I don't know
it's totally [ __ ] reality
mind-bending for me to watch that
like I don't know and like in that all
these people you know at a certain point
in time the one thing they have in
common is that they all live in this
underworld and they don't want the West
the rest of the world to like figure
yeah stay out of our business out of our
business that's the one thing that like
they all have in common stay out of our
business unless you want to come to our
business later on and pay for it and but
that's like it it's like the tip of the
iceberg is the zoo like I'll see these
pretty cats cool
that's that's this much and then beneath
it is like all the crazy [ __ ] [ __ ]
that goes on that nobody knew about
until they make a documentary about it I
just think it's a little it's hard to
understand what compels people to have
an exotic animal in the first place cuz
I mean you you hear about stuff like
that on the news you know and you know
that it exists that people have you see
it on tick tock on Instagram you'll see
these people in other countries for the
most part yeah but they'll post videos
and pictures of them with Tigers and all
kinds of you're like what the hell is
going on and I just don't it's confusing
to me although a dog in theory could
totally kill a person and attack a
person that to me is scary enough and
this is a domesticated animal yeah do
you want me to pick you back up but you
were biting me you're ruining our
podcast I just don't it's hard for me to
understand what would compel someone to
like really really want that well I
think she is by you you know I think
it's because I won't let him eat out I
think it's a level of I mean in the in
the age I mean even when before social
media like people would take pictures of
them to have a photograph of them with a
cat right but like today where you know
we live in such a 1-up ii kind of like
social media-driven like society with
friends and whatever and people and
social status like
I would imagine people view that as like
a huge leg up on whoever you're you know
eating with her or compared with in any
sort of sense and the regard for animal
life goes out the window at that point
because of the fact that you're you're
able to kind of seize this crazy
opportunity and be like oh I took a
picture I got to hang out with a big cat
that's where that's what I think it
comes from but to me I I like even just
watching the video or the the
documentary seeing video footage of
those cats next to people in
environments where they really really
just should not be and it doesn't look
right and it feels wrong it's it [ __ ]
is an interesting thing to look at
seeing those those cats next to people
it just is it's like voyeuristically as
a viewer I'm like wow yeah look at this
guy heading this 900-pound tiger what
the [ __ ] you know what I mean and so
it's like it really is just intriguing
and crazy but at no point what I ever
feel like that would cross over into my
real life decision-making to ever want
to do that ever I mean it's just so
wrong on so many levels but I just it's
intriguing the whole thing is walking in
trees so there's a couple of good points
there I forget one of the guys names was
talking about you know if there's an
endangered species of animal why
wouldn't you just make more I I'm not
saying that people should be breeding
Tigers but that logic is not necessarily
flawed but I think for people like
Carroll Baskins or you know they're
they're having a rescue and it talks at
the very end about how there's between
five and ten thousand captive Tigers in
the United States and there's less than
four thousand in the wild total yeah you
know what what would you do in terms of
making sure that Tigers didn't go
extinct number one and number two what
is the appropriate way to keep a tiger
captive if it's even okay or right or
ethical who do you who's the expert yeah
oh she's the expert because it's not
colonel baskem
if it's not her property I mean to be
fair we didn't really see the extent of
these people where they keep them and
you know
they don't give you like a tour you only
saw candles property or you know you see
shots of it
you don't we don't really know so you
haven't been there I haven't seen it
know you that's a good point inside note
you have to imagine the dock you the
dock crew spent most of their time
filming on on Joe exotics property and
when they went and filmed that dock
antle's and at Carroll Baskins you could
tell I mean maybe I could tell based on
the amount of outfits you would see
people wearing that they only had a
handful of days to film on those
properties yeah so that just adds fuel
to the fact that or your theory that
it's you know that they only had a few
shots or whatever they didn't get double
yeah yeah exactly they're talking about
how their properties 40 acres and I'm
like well you know I kind of saw like 10
shots of where a tiger was you know
that's not the scope of what their
property may or may not look like yeah
and then so even if people decided okay
this is an appropriate way to have an
animal who are the appropriate people to
take care of them is that a zoo is that
a private Zoo is it a person that's also
specialized in veterinary medicine for
exotic animal like who are the right
people and who are the wrong people and
what's right and what's wrong and should
it be in this country should it be in
other countries like you know what are
the rules and I think it just gets so
gray and so weird yeah well I mean you
have to think that for some entire like
society to form itself like this the
underground kind of big cat Society has
there has to be a real lapse in judgment
from lawmakers and the government right
cuz like how does any of this even get
started are they they're not all
smuggling [ __ ] illegally it means maybe
some of it right but there has to be
loopholes in the law that allow this to
happen so I think the first thing you
have to ask is like what are the laws
what is allowed what about besides like
killing people what in this documentary
is legal and what is illegal yeah you
don't I mean that's so interesting to me
because I don't [ __ ] know can you get
a cat from Africa or wherever and bring
it to your residence and just have it
there with you to do
is that straight-up is that legal or not
I don't know what are the stipulations
for that I think it's all interesting
because I don't I don't think a lot of
people know the answer to that I mean
maybe they do maybe I'm wrong and dumb
but I I genuinely am just like how would
this whole entire story be happening if
the laws were this is very legal and you
will get a felony you know if you have
no like there's loopholes there has to
be otherwise this wouldn't happen I just
I don't know yeah I don't know either I
mean it's even in within my lifetime you
we used to go to the circuits as kids
you know super [ __ ] up there's all
kinds of zoos and SeaWorld and all kinds
of stuff like that and it's only over
time as people exposed like what happens
to the animals and people learn more
about it that the law eventually maybe
catches up yeah but yeah privately-owned
zoo zoos in this country I I guess I've
probably gone unchecked for a little
while because they're like hey man you
got 40 acres and you got some Tigers and
you know if they maul you to death it's
on you that's that was your choice and
you're right as a landowner and as long
as they don't go near anybody you know
that seems like that was the approach
yeah but if you know it's exposed that
there's this like underground we're
selling Cubs and killing Cubs are
killing Tigers or there's a possibility
for them to get loose yeah yeah I mean
we'll probably see something change yeah
and and yeah but like also what's a zoo
right so like if you're and like what's
it called animal sanctuary but you only
have domesticated animals do the same
rules apply to you as someone that wants
to have six monkeys yeah you know yeah
do you I don't even know what an exotic
animal would be if you have a ostrich is
it an exotic animal is it a reptile I
don't
and the definition for an animal
sanctuary according to Wikipedia is a
facility where animals are brought to
live and be protected for the rest of
their lives
unlike animal shelters saying
sanctuaries do not seek place seek to
place animals with individuals or groups
instead maintaining each animal until
its natural death so that's the
definition of an animal sanctuary so
that would mean that because carol does
refer to her property Big Cat Rescue as
an animal sanctuary multiple times that
would mean that once she gets cats to be
you know on her property they're there
and cared for until they die right and
then if the law passed that you know
people were no longer allowed to keep
them as pets
it might be long after Carroll Baskins
you know lifetime but like in theory she
wouldn't have an animal sanctuary yeah
because there wouldn't be any cats to
rescue yeah yeah yeah that's true I
guess would be cool it just does feel
like there's this weird I don't know
legal loophole that she hides behind to
be able to call herself a sanctuary like
that because it really doesn't feel like
one I've been to an animal sanctuary you
know gentle barn
I mean it hasn't totally different like
group of animals that were talking about
and universes of people but still
nothing about I mean I feel like she was
really playing it up as this like Mother
Teresa for big cats like look at me I
have this flower crown and I care for
all these wonderful cats and they love
me but like no you don't pay any of your
employees you're rich is a [ __ ]
your facility doesn't really look up to
whatever code I'm sure exists I mean I
don't know it's just nothing about it
felt good well in these they're wild
animals well that's the number one reads
the number one thing it's like they're
big cats they shouldn't even be here
yeah it's a loaded yeah topic for sure
what do you do you know if somebody say
Joe exotic was abusing the Tigers really
badly yeah and then someone in law
enforcement was like we're taking him
away from you yeah where do you take
them who
you take them to who is qualified to you
know I just don't know I just know I
hear you it's it's so complex and it's
so they allowed to do with them are they
allowed to charge people money to come
see them like what are they allowed to
do yeah I don't know I'm in yep [ __ ]
no I don't know dude what I'm curious
about is the reality TV producer the
footage that burned down what the [ __ ]
did he have I wanted to see that footage
and what's crazy is like they already
had so much for us for this documentary
imagine what that hadn't burned down
imagine the footage they would have it
would have been twice as long yeah I do
feel bad because he he seemed pretty
devastated about that yeah [ __ ] and if
you if you're considering watching the
series and you haven't yet I want to
issue a trigger warning for episode 5
because holy [ __ ] [ __ ] there was none
and it really blindsided me and [ __ ]
me up for a little bit so just careful
episode 5 you know trigger on it but
couldn't recommend the series enough I
mean it was incredible entertainment and
really well done and just makes you
think and I feel like was something like
you know I both the subject matter right
this whole you know community of people
who had big cats and then also just like
the characters and the people if they're
all just everything is so interesting
about it just wild
with fascinating personal lives
fascinating but how how it just can't be
enough that you run an exotic animal
private Zoo you have to go and have
these outrageously fascinating
experiment what the hell yeah I know
damn right yeah it's crazy it's
absolutely crazy I don't know I I just I
think that's that's human nature to be
curious as to how
other people live their lives but like
what a fascinating group of people very
fascinating yeah well we binge that in
like a couple days so I'm glad we had
that content to consume our time with
and think about see grumble he's a
grumble boy grumble grumble Sarah me
bonk your head I couldn't but we've been
I feel like we've been dealing with the
situation alright um um you know we're
trying to be as good about like having a
routine as we can and what are you doing
play with the dogs get outside time it's
been weird because on top of all that's
going on we're we're having especially
erratic weather right now where one day
it's sunny and then next two days it's
raining and so on top of getting the
littles to go outside rain isn't really
they don't love it and on top of not
being able to leave the house can't even
leave the house house into our yard
somedays because this raining so and
then we find a poop in the dining room
even though we've blocked the dining
room off when we know exactly who pooped
in there because they're the only one
that can jump over the little barricade
we made are we talking about peace no I
don't think I mentioned it online but
[ __ ] so ridiculous what we noticed that
like a few months ago we noticed when we
would leave for our workouts which would
hey my guy when we would leave for our
workouts which would be one of the few
times that we would both be out of the
house together for them I mean for the
most part I usually was here yeah it's
when we go work out but it would only be
when we both left we would notice that
every once in a while would come back
and in the dining room there would be a
little baby poop a little eggy poop and
we're like hmm it's interesting because
there's two AG's so it could be either
of you because bunnies in her crate when
we leave and marbles he usually just
like passes out for two hours and wakes
up and he's like where am I
and so I thought okay easy solution
let's take a couple of our our boxes of
you know unused things or you know
having some there's like a planter in my
endurance middle just some packed
footstool that we like barricaded off
the dining really barricaded off we put
like you know like a little bit of a
wall like that's above their head it's
like a tall for an egg it's tall for for
them you know they can't in our mind
they can't get through it so for a
little while I feel like it got better
there were less and less poops and then
they started to pop back up
but the barricade remains there there
was no less of a barricade but then the
poops were magically appearing in that
room again and so we really quote the
heck dude and so one time I move the
barricade I walk in there I'm cleaning
up the poop and Peach follows me and I
man I'm annoyed because I'm like hey
don't you come in here while I'm
cleaning up potentially your poop and I
say peach get out and she runs the other
way and jumps the barricade to leave the
ring it was not like it was nothing she
bunny hops the barricade and clears it
by a whole foot and just runs to the
living room and I'm like you just
exposed yourself you didn't even realize
it and then now every single time as the
poop in here
she doesn't even realize it but she's
like it was me it's like you're the only
one that can get over that marbles sure
as [ __ ] can't Kermit definitely can't
bunny is in her crate I'm pretty sure
those are all of our dogs
so peach is guilty you knew it was peach
that's one of the reasons that she owes
general a lot of money
no she didn't pay it back anyway thanks
for the haircut Jenny gave me a haircut
the other day feel really really lucky
to have got their hair not too late to
join the haven't cut your hair in three
years team in case you want to come to
the dark side it's pretty great here
well if you have a roommate significant
other sibling whatever make them cut
your hair it might turn out good
that's not it well it might might not
well it also might it also might no and
if it might not no one's gonna see you
cuz you're in your house sure oh what's
that blood wasn't it what now what are
we doing now he's been a lot today he
screamed he bit me he demanded pizza in
a mug you were a nuisance this podcast I
think it was a combination of eating
good smelling food in front of him
before he's had his dinner yeah we
should feed you dinner button yeah you
ready for dinner
ready for dinner you want dinner you
want farmers to do anyway um sorry if
this was lame we're trying our best to
keep the content feeling like normal and
good but you know the world's not normal
the world's not normal so it is hard we
hope you guys are all doing okay and
you're staying safe but we'll see you
guys next week for another podcast if
you have ideas though for podcast right
now like you know we're open to them so
leave them in the comments or tweet them
at us at general Julien on Twitter and
we'll try to try to get some good [ __ ]
pumped out for you good content right
yeah it's just it's easier right now I
like to you know when you want to lift
your mood will turn on like parks and
rec or Seinfeld or something and it's
easy to forget this is not present-day
this was filmed some other time when I
was easy to be light and happy and it's
making anything right now can get a
little difficult you know yeah well we
were trying our best but we're also
trying not to be insensitive so yeah but
it was a very nice
welcome distraction to watch Tiger King
because it just helps you get lost
because yeah it gets you lost in a
different world
so I'm lost into exhaust world and how
many people just did not wear shirts the
entire time that they filmed that for
those of you who let me get on that
level just someone's like hey I'm
filming a thing so I just take my shirt
off and [ __ ] so you know this I'm not
worried too sure it for any of this if
you watch it I hope you enjoyed our
discussion and let us know your thoughts
on it below we'd love to hear anyway
we'll see you guys next week have a good
week and stay safe be good and you know
[Music]
for a whole week straight
[Music]